Speaker 1: This is super, super interesting.
And or at least I found it.
So there was a so there's a mayoral race in
New York City.
We're going to talk on the bonus show today
a little bit about Andrew Yang's recent Twitter
controversy.
Andrew Yang, as a candidate in the New York
City mayoral race recently, the New York Times
editorial board interviewed each of the candidates.
And this is something that many newspapers
do for presidential races or sometimes Senate
or whatever the case may be with the mayoral
race.
The New York Times interviews the candidates
and they ask the candidates, do you know the
median sales price for a home in Brooklyn?
OK, now, I used to live in Brooklyn and at
the time when I last lived there, which was
I guess when was I last in that neighborhood
in 2015.
If at the time you had asked me the median
home price, I think I would have said 550000
based on my understanding of of home prices
there.
And two of the candidates were asked about
this, Shaun Donovan and Raymond McGuire, and
they were so far off that it's almost like,
do you have any idea what's going on in the
city?
Shaun Donovan said, I don't know for sure.
I would guess around 100000 dollars, which,
you know, when I see that, I wonder if you're
that out of touch with what's going on with
home prices in Brooklyn.
What else that's fundamental to the New York
City experience right now, do you have no
idea about?
And then Raymond McGuire, who's an investment
banker and former Citigroup executive, was
very similar.
He said it's probably between 80 and 90 thousand
dollars, if not higher.
Now, I'm no real estate expert.
You know, I'm involved in a number of properties
in different parts of the country.
And I have, you know, sort of like a passing
knowledge of the fact that in East Coast cities
and and West Coast cities, properties are
really expensive.
Then you have sort of secondary cities like,
you know, Austin and Asheville, where property
values are going up, but there's still quite
a bit less.
And then you've got rural you know, I have
like a passing sense of it.
How on earth do you get to 80, 90 or 100 thousand
dollar median home price in Brooklyn?
Now, later, one of the candidates said, well,
I thought you meant assessed value.
It still doesn't make any sense.
Eric Adams, who's the Brooklyn borough president,
said he thought the number was 550.
That's the number I would have guessed back
in 2015.
Maya Wiley, former counsel to Bill de Blasio,
just one point eight million, and Andrew Yang
correctly guessed 900000.
It's that that that's that's basically right
where we are.
So how much do you think this is relevant
in thinking about whether a candidate can
properly manage a city from the standpoint
of if you so misunderstand something as fundamental
as cost of living, if you underestimate by
eight ninths the cost of a median home in
Brooklyn, what else are you going to be unable
to sort of empathize with or understand?
To me, it does seem like a real problem.
Now, I this, by the way, I don't know how
many of you have seen.
Bill Gates was interviewed by Ellen DeGeneres
a couple of years ago, and they did a sort
of similar thing where Ellen asked Bill Gates,
you know, what do you think, milk costs or
whatever.
And Bill Gates had, like, no idea there was
like some little frozen food thing.
And Bill Gates thought it cost twenty bucks
when it's like, you know, if if that thing
cost twenty bucks, then, you know, it just
didn't didn't make any sense.
Is this relevant?
I think it is relevant, I kind of did a self-test
where I wrote down, what do I think, gasoline,
the average home in Miami, a gallon of milk,
bread and a gallon of eggs cost just to see
if I had some sense of the sort of like national
numbers.
So for gasoline, I guess three dollars and
I haven't gotten gas for a while.
I've had an electric car for for some time
now.
And gasoline right now is at 301 nationally.
So that's just like a random guess.
I seemed sort of clued in to that average
house in Miami, which is a market I sort of
know, but not intimately.
I guess the median home price in Miami is
three hundred and fifty thousand.
Real number is three hundred ninety eight
thousand.
So I'm sort of testing whether if you're at
all connected to what's going on in the country,
you would be in the ballpark.
And the more I was guessing these numbers,
the more I think guessing 100000 for a Brooklyn
median home price if you're running for mayor
is a major red flag, average price of a gallon
of milk.
Now, I did struggle with this because, first
of all, I never buy a gallon.
And I know when you buy less, the price per
per per ounce goes up.
I also admittedly, I get hipster milk.
I get like the pasture raised organic.
I pay like five bucks for a half gallon, I
guess for a gallon of organic milk.
It's five dollars.
It's actually four.
And similarly with eggs, ever since reading
Michael Pollan's books about this, I've decided
the extra couple bucks for pastured eggs and
pastured milk.
I've just decided it's worth it.
I don't consume so much that it really makes
a big difference.
So like with eggs, I'm getting those like
bright orange yolk eggs or whatever.
It's like six bucks a dozen.
So I guess for like your basic cage free eggs,
it's probably something like three dollars
and it turns out it's two sixty six.
And then lastly for bread, I struggled with
bread because like, you know, the difference
between a loaf of processed wonder bread and
artisanal seed bread or whatever, it seems
like it's the difference between a dollar
and eight dollars.
I don't know, I guess three dollars.
The official rate for bread is two dollars
and fifty cents.
So, like, how relevant is this stuff?
If you're listening to a candidate say that
they hear they hear you about the issues in
your city, they believe they can fix some
of those issues.
They want to bring this and they want to bring
that.
And then you ask them, what do you think a
medium home value is when it's nine hundred
thousand and they say eighty grand?
That seems to me like a material concern.
And I'm curious to hear from you whether you
agree.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We will take a quick break.
And we have so much
more upcoming.